brian laundry's body has been found the
discovery follows weeks of speculation
about the 23-year-old's whereabouts also
breaking tonight the fbi says that the
skeletal remains found in a nature
preserve in florida on wednesday are in
fact those of brian laundry law
enforcement had considered laundry the
only person of interest in the murder of
his fiancee gabby petito the discovery
comes one day after a stunning update
from the fbi which held a press
conference outside of this florida
nature preserve
investigators found what appears to be
human remains
along with personal items such as a
backpack
and notebook belonging to brian laundry
in a statement on thursday the fbi says
comparisons of dental records confirmed
the human remains found are those of
laundry
an attorney for laundry's parents also
released this statement chris and
roberta laundry have been informed that
the remains found yesterday in the
reserve are indeed brian's we have no
further comment at this time and we ask
that you respect the laundry's privacy
at this time on wednesday it was
reported that laundry's father had gone
to the nature preserve looking for signs
of his son
so we know that this is an area that had
been previously submerged underwater and
we do know that chris laundry has been
out here before helping investigators
search we were also told that they had
to search in in several areas but this
area again only recently has dried up
and allowed for more access into the
park laundry and potito spent this past
summer traveling across the country
documenting their trip on social media
laundry returned to his parents florida
home with the couple's van but without
petito who was officially reported
missing on september 11th days later
potito's body was found near grand teton
national park the teton county coroner's
office is following the following
verdict in the manner of death of
gabrielle lenora potito
we find the cause and manner to be
caused death by strangulation and manner
is homicide the potato family has voiced
suspicions of the laundry family i do
believe they know a lot more information
than they're
putting out there
that's potito's parents speaking with dr
phil earlier this month vann got there
and whatever happened with his parents
after that i don't know but you can only
speculate we don't know yeah i honestly
don't know and to be honest with you
they probably wouldn't tell the truth to
begin with and
despite gabby's parents calling and
calling they won't tell gabby's family
she's not there and that she's missing
e.t spoke with legal expert nancy grace
about the case and the possible
ramifications for laundry's parents
many legal eagles have been speculating
as to whether brian laundry's parents
can be charged with a crime
here's the deal
under our jurisprudence you don't have
to be a hero you don't have to go to
cops and tell them what you saw or tell
them what you know
you don't have to save someone from a
crime you don't have to do anything
you're not compelled
to tell the truth to police however
if you do speak to police and they have
if you lie
that is a crime so if they have remained
silent and not misled law enforcement
they may escape criminal liability
right now they are saying
to the effect oh the fbi jogged our
memories now we remember the last time
we saw our son
it was the day before i find that very
hard to believe